oh yeah unusual the first thing it hits
from here is your eyeball
yo that's a bad sign
wow
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by bear grylls he's
an adventurer best-selling author and
the battle tested host of a number of
hit shows including running wild with
bear grylls which returns for its july
25th premiere on national geographic
today though the man who's feasted his
way through live scorpions and a yaks
eyeball tries his hand at the wings of
death bear grylls welcome to the show
hey nice to be with you
a little apprehensive when they lifted
that that was like how oh it cuts
through the air yeah yeah but don't
psych yourself out just yet i know that
you're an adventurous eater how are you
around spicy food probably not brilliant
this kind of similar dynamic that we
have on running wild really in the sense
you know what you're doing i'm the
rookie
elaborative but i'm
ready to go
[Music]
yeah
and look we've got
beef as well hot ones first just for you
bear grylls yes thank you i don't know i
love
i love beef yeah this is great this is
new for me
[Music]
um
[Music]
yeah i mean this is how i eat good steak
a little bit of something hot
but i definitely hang around this side
not today though that's so good
so running wild isn't an interview show
at its heart but there's no denying that
you get these very real moments with
your celebrity guests that you'd never
see on a late night talk show how do you
intellectualize how these extreme
environments open people up and perhaps
make them more relatable
you look at a chat show
it's always a performance isn't it
somebody's got three minutes to be funny
and tell a kind of great story or
whatever and i always struggle with that
because it's
never feels real you know
and i think as you know you go out with
someone a buddy and you hike a trail and
you know get involved in in nature in
the outdoors for a bit
you have you have conversations that are
much more real and running well is just
an extreme version of that you know i
think after you've faced a few fears and
you've you know you've got a trust
between each other people open up
that's why i always say i think the wild
is the star of the show really does my
job for me
[Music]
the double lock yeah
[Music]
hmm
so good that one's really good the steak
the sort of tropical vibe with that
well my wife said she goes
you're going to be terrible at that show
you hate really spicy stuff and i'm
probably not great really spicy stuff
but
right here
it's dreamy it's very nice you might
notice something here note to self
don't wipe my eye or scratch my balls
scratch your balls after you've been
messing around with the bomb right
you might not live to tell the tale yeah
okay i'm over
so i understand that will ferrell
legitimately struggled after eating a
caribou's eye and i've heard deion
sanders tell his story of clinging to
the mesa rock wall a thousand feet up
when you think of the celebrities who've
impressed you the most with the size of
their adventure bug is there a name that
stands out
you know sometimes guests arrive and
they they want the whole nine yards you
know they say give it give it all and
there's a little part of me that's
always like
be careful what you wish for because the
wild again tends to do it anyway you
know somebody is you know it's
unpredictable you're going to get some
bad weather or the water levels higher
than you
and you always got to improvise a little
bit so
for will ferrell i mean i will always be
indebted and love that man you know he
was our first ever guest we took him to
the arctic
you know in those days we'd go for days
and days you know now it's much shorter
and tighter and you know we've learned
otherwise if you break people you don't
get anything out of them after a while
but will we didn't know that at this
stage so will was in the deep end and
still to this day if i see him
he goes first of all
people still talk to you about that show
and secondly because it was the hardest
thing i've ever done in my life and i go
well you're a truly amazing man on the
shoulders of giants we all stand
will ferrell is one of them for me
[Music]
wow somebody's put a lot of sauce on
this one
this is like marinated we thought you
wanted the whole 12 yards
did i ever ask for the whole 12 yards
hmm
getting a little punchier yeah this one
so you do lure it in with the first two
then cover the third you guys are gonna
have a slick pattern to this
blow you into a false sense of security
and then
bring it
saving the milk
yeah there we go
so in 2019 mountaineer near mall persia
posted a viral photo of a traffic jam of
climbers at the top of mount everest how
does that photo compare to your memories
of being one of the youngest people to
climb the summit when you did it back in
1988 yeah that photo was amazing nims is
a good buddy of mine he's you know an
incredible high-altitude mountaineer
but you know i think you've got to kind
of roll with the times and
you know part of me thinks that's
amazing you know and and people way
younger and wailed and without limbs and
you know and i would never want to take
anything away from those guys because at
the end of the day you've got to climb
it you know the
the weather forecasting has got better
the gear has got better and the oxygen
has got way lighter you know
why so many people would die so you're
so slow you're carrying so much weight
those progressions are great and i don't
stand in the way of progress
so um i look back on those times
super lucky to have got the chance to do
it and
grateful to got away with my life what
others hunt at that stage and
ever grateful for the friendships with
the geysers without them
[Music]
this one's green as well which makes me
suspicious
definitely getting into harder territory
your eyes are watering if your eyes are
watering i'm dead
i'm trying to put up a calm front you
know thank you almost like you would do
on your show you know i'm trying to be
that support system
i loved it when gordon gordon was such a
good episode
so fun wasn't it
loving going you [ __ ]
we'll never forget that here in the
studio
i was feeling much more boring guess
sorry
off the top of your head and without
thinking about it too much what would
you say is the seminal or all-time
greatest adventure novel
ha interesting
unbroken an incredible story you know
the louis vampirini they made it into a
film which kind of
lost so much really because the book is
insane you know he was an american
soldier the second world war his plane
crashed in the pacific
ended up in
one of the longest survival life for our
stories in history
whilst being strafed by japanese you
know enemy aircraft and
shark attacks and
most of them died a couple eventually
made it and you think you finally make
it onto this island
but the island was
one of the most horrific japanese prison
war camps and his journey was only just
beginning and he
survived nagasaki nuclear bombs i mean
you know the transport ships from hell
you know his story is amazing
he was broken in so many ways afterwards
but he found healing and he found a
faith in his life and a great family and
he set up these amazing you know
youth programs and um
true hero
i'm breaking into the milk we're halfway
you know it's bad when there's a devil
on horseback
we're at that point in the world grim
reaper yeah they start threatening you
through the marketing
trying not to get it on the lips smart
all right bear in the meantime though we
have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that graham where we do a
deep dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so we'll pull the picture up
over here on the monitor you just tell
us the bigger story
i love this quote of yours life
shouldn't be a journey to the grave with
the intention of showing up in an
attractive and well-preserved body do
you have an injury or scar that holds
the most meaning to you
yeah but i got a private one i'm gonna
keep that one private
um
i think you know my back
my back accident you know breaking my
back in three places was a
was a life-changing journey for me you
know it's a fruitful accident jump went
wrong i spent best part of a year in and
out of army rehabilitation struggling to
be able to reach a bathroom you know
it's just strapped up in braces and my
back never lets me
forget it and i think the thing that's
not letting me forget is a number one
don't be an idiot you only get it wrong
once be smart
and always be grateful for life you know
because i should there'd be so many
times i should have died and i'm still
going and i'm you know
so grateful for that it's only great
whether it's sitting eating crazy you
know stuff with you or whatever it's
life's a great privilege and uh and i
think that's what the pain in the back
always reminds me of
every day
i'm really enjoying this
yeah the clue is
on the scale of how how hot it is
there's a lot of chilies down the bottom
i'm hanging on in there
i can see it trying to pace myself the
determination i see it come on never
give up we're gonna get the training
it's all it's led to this
[Laughter]
so besides obvious exceptions like david
attenborough there aren't that many
people who've been making television out
in remote areas of the world long enough
to see the effects of climate change are
there obvious changes that you've
noticed in your decades of doing
expeditions that give you pause
climate change is undeniable and the
other thing about climate change is that
it always affects the vulnerable you
know in terms not just in terms of
wildlife which i've seen some horrific
consequences of
of climate change upon and you know
animals and you know when you see 50
elephants
fighting in a mud hole with sort of that
much mud in it that you know for
hundreds of years there's been a full up
and you see these elephants starving to
death and so yeah it's it's hard to come
away unaffected
but the other
side of it is that climate change
affects vulnerable people coastal
communities the poorest people in the
world rising sea levels extreme droughts
extreme rainfalls flash flood you know
and that's the one thing we all share
together the same planet and i come from
the position of if you love something
you protect it
and uh and that's how i see climate
change
[Music]
oh wow i've just found the knife and
fork
yeah yeah here's to you
wow
is that a bomb worse
a lot worse yeah i'm not going to lie to
you
i
i appreciate the fact you're honest i am
struggling a little bit with this one
[Music]
come on bear there we go let's go bear
you got it you've got a bear you've got
a fire there we go
it's like it's like anti-venom
yeah
i've never heard this analogy before but
i'm all yours well with you know we're
in jungles all the time
a lot of snakes in fact one of our one
of our guys got bitten by a horrific
snake and that's a whole nother story
i'll send you the i'll send you the
photo of steve's foot after that snake
yeah i gotta see steve's terrific but um
this is hot ones auntie venom
that's taking me close to the water team
[Music]
good here we go there we go
i'm really feeling the urge to scratch
my balls
don't yeah i appreciate it i appreciate
it yeah like dive on that like secret
service
from across the table
okay
so there's a recurring question that
we've asked before on hot ones to anyone
who can give a credible answer and i
think that we can add you to the list
alongside padma lakshmi and andrew
zimmern of all the animal testicles that
you've eaten in your life which ones do
you think have the best shot at becoming
a mainstream menu item if people gave
them a chance
well first of all
none of them because they're all pretty
terrible
and there have been a few test schools
over the years you know
i mean the worst testicle was the goat's
testicle in the sahara that uh this
berber tries when it cut off
and uh and i saw the goat before and it
was quite a small goat i thought this is
gonna be okay until i saw the size of
the testicles and i thought that that is
out of all proportion
anyway i tried to eat this thing
uh
thought i'd try and swallow it because i
didn't want to bite into this massive
testicle that was just going to get ugly
so i tried to swallow this thing and it
got halfway down but it was too big so i
threw it up now having a mouthful and
then bit down so now i got
tesco sacks sperm and vomit in my mouth
you know but i didn't want to be rude so
i tried to hold it there
and then eventually kind of got it down
yeah that was a bad day yeah
wow i'm i'm suddenly getting a lot of
kick from a build-up of eight this is
the cumulative effect yeah yeah i'm
getting that well wait till and i
haven't even done the
wait until this sort of once that bomb
goes down there's no going back there's
not going right we're in it before we do
dead bomb is there anything sensible
you'd like to ask me because
right sure the answers might get us
slightly well listen i don't know if
you've been following along so far but
nothing i ask is sensible you know
yeah unusual there the first thing it
hits from here is your eyeball
yo that's a bad sign
wow
mother love yeah wow yeah
come on team
never give up
get the milk get more milk ready
we should yeah maybe it's payback over
like so many there's so many guests
we've had have been so many moments of
kind of raw terror and raw this is
payback this is a long time i have a lot
of running mob
oh buddies watching this going
you mother lover this has been long
overdue yeah
yeah in all of your years of shooting
what would you say was the most
inopportune time to experience diarrhea
halfway up a rock face i had that on a
on a big cliff and
i'd eaten a dodgy snake the day before
and um
wow
and anyway i was halfway up this rock
face
and um and i felt it coming you know
and as you know when it comes you can't
there's nowhere to know where to hide
and i said the camera guy said look turn
the camera off
this ain't waiting for no one you know
because i had a hand up here on this
thing you know
one hour on the road the other on trying
to get my trousers down
did the business
into free air you know crew underneath
it
oh no
and uh
and i told her to tell the camera to
turn the camera off and i eventually got
sorted and you know holding on and tied
my train look looks over there and
there's cameras all blinking still you
know
there's nothing sacred
oh wow
i know
no but the other thing i've learned on
this journey with you
respect
respect for you you know good for you i
mean you do this day in day out
[Music]
you know i'm i'm a de bomb virgin
and it's probably going to be a one-time
one-time relationship you know good for
you wow
[Music]
wow it doesn't get any better does it
[Music]
what's a politically correct word for
man up
step up human up yeah humanoid
and no fun no fun at all
but after the last one
a little bit nicer yeah although
that hurt the teeth
right they kind of all
were a lot different i mean that's a new
experience trying to hurt the teeth
you know
you'd never call that you know if you're
a viewer watching this at home you think
hot things mouth you know lips
for something to hurt your teeth
different level
so i imagine there have been times in
your life where fans will approach you
on the street to tell you how something
they saw you do on tv actually saved
them in a potentially life-threatening
real-life situation
what is the story that stands out when
you think about those stranded and lost
stories that you've heard from fans over
the years
[Applause]
um well
oh they're being some great piece of
good stories you know
you know great ones are like snowballs
getting lost and you know a few few
drinking urine
ah
you know kids falling through the ice
there have been some pretty hardcore
serious incidents for that and then kids
have been amazing and remembered
something and
you know fall through the ice you're not
gonna remember complicated difficult
things but simple things like turn
around and go back out the way you came
rather than panicking and
trying to you know
simple things
uh
rolling in the snow you know so snow can
absorb the water off you you know
obviously dry snow it's going to take
the water away it's water ultimately
with windshields going to make you cold
so great stories like that i love i love
hearing them we get them the whole time
and never tire of it so many heroes out
there
[ __ ] my massive [ __ ]
wow
i'm not entirely sure where we go from
here all right
so this is the last dab we call it the
last dab because it's tradition around
here to put a little extra on the last
wing or the last stake
but today such an error
such an error licking the lips it's been
such a day of firsts yeah that i think
we should do a first here on wing 10
with the dab yeah i understand that
you've brought some snacks and you're
not the only one we kind of had the same
idea here ally
coming through from bugaboo you're not
the only one okay with the bug plug over
here it's good it's good i mean i was
always taught never turn up for a party
empty-handed so
you're so kind thank you
so i bought a little present for you
yeah so we should i bought some maggots
here here we go
there you go you got that all these go
because he's the only one
we've got some worms over here
so what there we go so
yep you have the maggots i'll have your
i'll have your worms i'll just do a
little bit of both guys these are these
are not oh they are worms yeah yeah like
well they're grubs you know
these look like these have been
marinating something already
well allie seasons over here
oh
[ __ ] that's not a dab that's a marinade
yeah yeah be careful over there hold on
let's go again on this so that's a dab
here we go
cheers bear hey it's been a privilege if
we don't come out the other end of this
experience it was all worth it it's been
an honor brother it's been an honor here
we go here's to you to you
[Music]
um
okay
[Music]
there's a reason you save it for the
last
yeah yeah but i don't imagine you have
many recurring guests
you know we have a handful but we
probably have
similar
problems similar things going on it's so
funny isn't it there's so much of it
like when i was reading your book
everything that i was hit everything was
like i was like yes yes i never felt
more seen than reading the same sort of
challenges and then the same sort of
effects that you guys have doing your
show where it does open people up or
yeah you have this thing celebrity that
is by definition unobtainable but
there's no artifice there's nowhere to
hide in the wild and there's nowhere to
hide with the hot sauce yeah well i i
love that and and you create connections
as you say you go through kind of
hot scary things again you know you're
gonna create some connections but um
but yeah you you do you do an amazing
job you know wow good for you
but no like you were saying you know
probably not many recurring guests we
have a few on running wilds we have
satan's come back a couple of times and
a few others but
but yeah mostly it's like an experience
it's like hot ones it's amazing epic but
we're done
off the dab we're done you know and it's
a bit like that day two are running
while they go better this is
being unbelievable and blow my mind
we're out of never want to see you again
but you know what bear grylls we saw the
challenge we took it on and we climbed
to the summit of mount scoville and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life
oh wow i have to i like enjoy the thing
to then plug the show
you guys will figure it out you'll
figure it out yeah hey for me more
importantly than plugging anything you
know it's just um
i love it it's been a brilliant
privilege to do it with you and
i'm honored you read the book first of
all you're so kind that'd be a good one
plug never give up by that i'm running
one running while that's why we're here
it's like brain fog running one new
season out now amazing guest
wow that down
[Applause]
epic such a pleasure
i would actually i would class that as a
household hazard yeah yeah i think so
that goes along with bleach
you know sulfuric acid the machetes the
axes
that you know you don't need in your
house don't have it
anyway so fun so fun
hey what's going on hot ones fans we
brought the heat to the freezer aisle
with our hot ones boneless chicken bites
and used smash sales records and all of
our wildest expectations so what did we
do we made more that's right we are in
with five new flavors of hot ones
boneless chicken bites and five new ways
for you to bring hot ones home from the
classic to the classic garlic fresno
edition to the los calientes trio of
flavor verde rojo barbacoa visit hot
ones challenge dot com for more
information and to find a store near you
hot ones boneless chicken bites you're
in the hot seat now